Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we are going to see whether NVIDIA’s
modern AI system they call MineDojo
can learn to play and build
things in Minecraft and more.
In an earlier episode, we explored a previous
project that goes by the name GANCraft,
which performed world to world translation.
What is that? Well, simple, we give an AI a
very rough draft of a virtual world, and out
comes a much more detailed and beautiful one.
This almost seems like science fiction. Really,
just dream up something, and it makes it happen.
And, it gets better, it created water,
it understands the concept of an island,
and it created a beautiful landscape,
also, with vegetation. Insanity. It even
seems to have some concept of reflections,
although they will need some extra work to get it
perfectly right. It even supported interpolation,
which means that we can create one landscape and
ask the AI to create a blend between different
styles. We just look at the output animations, and
pick the one that we like best. And, with this,
finally, we also have some artistic control over
the mood of the results. Absolutely amazing.
But then they thought, why stop there? For
instance, DeepMind has a long history of
using AI systems to master all kinds of
games, from Chess, to Go, to StarCraft 2,
OpenAI has a DOTA2 AI project that is
able to challenge a world champion team,
so, NVIDIA thought, why not try their hands
at Minecraft? Minecraft is an open world game,
one of the most played games in the world,
which is kind of like a virtual sandbox.
Here, you can build things, explore, but really,
do whatever you wish. It’s a sandbox after all.
So scientists at NVIDIA thought, let’s train an AI
to play this game and see what happens. Okay, but
how? Well, most AI systems of today require
lots and lots of training data. Wait a minute.
There is no shortage of that out there in the
internet, that’s for sure. Let me explain.
We can have this little AI sit down and
watch hundreds of thousands of Minecraft
tutorial videos on Youtube, 33 years of footage
in total, my goodness, then, have it read over 7
thousand wiki pages, and then also becomes the
ultimate Reddit lurker. Wow. That makes a ton
of sense. Just think about it. It can learn
practical knowledge from the tutorial videos,
encyclopedic knowledge from the wiki, and
it can learn what makes the best creations
the best that are shared on reddit. That sounds
fantastic…on paper. But, there is so much to do
and to learn about this game, can an AI
really get an understanding of all this? Now,
hold on to your papers, and let’s see together
what this AI could learn from all this data!
But wait a minute! This is a gamer AI
that uses the controller to move around in
a virtual world. But how do we instruct it?
Do we need to speak robot? If not, well,
it doesn’t even understand English text. What do
we do with that? Well, remember OpenAI’s GPT-3,
which is a neural network model that
has read almost the entirety of the
internet. This one has proper English
knowledge, so, we plug that in, and bam,
now you can read that wikipedia, and it gets
better, because we can now even give it text
instructions. Now let’s see how well it
fares through 5 of my favorite examples.
One, we can ask it to explore an ocean monument.
I love this one because the text description
is sufficiently vague. How could a machine
understand what exploring means? Well, humans do,
and this learns from humans as there must be
tons of tutorial videos out there on exploration.
And, it seems to me that it was able to
learn the concept correctly. Loving it.
Two, it can encircle these llamas with a fence.
That is excellent. It understands what object
it needs to use, where to move, where to look,
and that not even a tiny gap
is allowed. Very impressive.
Three, this will be a more dangerous quest.
Now scoop a bucket of lava. Oh my goodness.
Be careful there! Do not fall!
We are getting there, and…got it!
Four, we can even ask it to build a nether
portal. It builds the correct portal
frame and, did it use the correct materials?
Does it work? Yes and yes! Good job little AI!
And, five. It is final boss time. Literally.
Oh yes. Someone was brave enough to ask the AI
to fight an ender dragon, essentially
the final boss of the game,
and the AI was brave enough to try it.
Well, apparently, this is a limited example
as it does not appear to be charging at the AI,
but, the AI seems to know what we are looking for,
and what fighting entails in this
game. Starting this game from scratch
and building up everything to defeat such a
dragon takes a long time horizon, and will be
an excellent benchmark for the next AI one more
paper down the line. I’d love to it perform this
start to end. Make sure to subscribe, if such a
paper appears, I’ll be here to show it to you.
While we are looking at more examples of
what it could do, I have to note that we have
barely scratched the surface here.
For instance, it understands text,
yes, but if we attach a speech recognition AI
to this agent, we don’t even need to write.
It can essentially be a little virtual friend.
How cool is that? What a time to be alive!
Okay, so this is MineDojo, an AI
agent that understands English,
and can learn to navigate these virtual worlds
so well, we can give it a task, and they would
execute it. And not just some simple ones, we
are talking a wide variety of complex tasks.
Now, all this footage looks great,
but how do we know if this is really
performing these tasks correctly? Well, if
you have been holding on to your papers, now,
squeeze that paper, because they had an
experienced human evaluator look at these results,
and agreed with the AI’s solutions about 97%
of the time. Wow. That is an incredible result.
And don’t forget, NVIDIA is amazing at
democratizing these works and putting them
into the hands of everyone, and this
one is an excellent example of that.
If you have some programming knowledge,
you can give it a try right now.
So, does this get your mind going? What would you
use this for? Let me know in the comments below!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!